every artist i ever met
and ever did business with me they'd
give me a number and i'm
telling what their number is i'm gonna
get the deal higher than that because i
know the promoters are gonna really pay
and that's the relationship you want
with big you because i'm gonna make sure
you get paid your money
when when the migos came i had the
amigos book
for three shows at 15 000 a piece
danny glover goes on the grammys and
they ask him what is he listening to
he says i'm listening to them madam
boujee yeah bad and boost yep it was
over after that
and yeah the number went from 15 000 to
100
yeah i remember i was trying to book
them at that time yeah
i'm aware but i was the only one who who
they was led booking them because i had
a relationship with them through atlanta
from italy
all right you know what i mean so and
and that's what
that's what that's what you know we do
as power brokers in this in this
industry
it ain't it ain't violence it ain't you
know it ain't the [ __ ] but i might
know the promoter you don't want to deal
with
right i might know the promoter who who
ain't going to pay you
i might know look you don't want to
charge radio
you want to do this no you don't want to
take 30 of your homeboys to this concert
and backstage
and y'all risked it and getting into
with somebody aeg
right you get into with aeg you can't
play no concerts around yeah you're
[ __ ]
that's what we do for sure